I want to talk some more about breaking
news this hour regarding the teenager
killed in a crash involving an American
driver Harry Dunne who was 19 died when
his motorbike collided with a car
outside an RAF base in Northamptonshire
in August we're now joined by the
family's lawyer mr. rad Seager who's in
Washington mr. Seeger thank you for
taking the time to speak to us we've had
a statement I think from you but perhaps
you could just clear up what is going to
happen with you and mr. coulis who was
involved in this incident over the next
few days yeah sure good evening so so
I've just just arrived in in Washington
a few hours ago and shortly after I
arrived I I had a message to say that a
legal representative had been appointed
for mrs. mrs. sue Kulas the the driver
and was trying to reach out to me that
I'd been on a plane and so yeah I called
her back as soon as I could and we've
had a very brief conversation and
pleased to say that we've agreed that we
will try to meet together just she and I
at the earliest possible opportunity
hopefully sometime this coming week but
it's depending on getting Diaries
together so that was her lawyer reaching
out to you rather than a request from
your side Oh correct correctly as you
probably gathered we've issued many
appeals over the last couple of weeks
for for either mrs. sue coulis or the
United States government to come and
talk to us and we heard nothing so yes a
couple of hours after I landed I got a
message to say that that mrs. sue
coolest or her lawyer was was trying to
get a hold of me yeah so I called her
back as soon as I could and yeah we'll
help try and get together sometime this
week is that meeting going to be just
between yourself and her representatives
is there a chance that the family could
meet either either her legal
representative or indeed her at any
point on this trip
well I think I think again it was it was
only it was only a couple of minutes of
a discussion I think what we agreed was
that she and I would get together first
and that's what that would be common and
in those circumstances for the for the
referee or the representatives of each
of each side to get together and then
maybe scope out what what what what
might happen I you know as you as you
probably know by now Harry's parents are
are flying out to New York tomorrow so
we're all physically together on the you
know on the same continent for a couple
of days
I know I know Diaries are jam-packed
with various commitments and I daresay
mrs. siccola sees lawyer is very busy as
well I I think it's unlikely that we
will be able to get both sides together
but in all likelihood I'll meet with
mrs. akula's lawyer first and then we
will scope out a further meeting and
we'll see where we go and you know it's
a great sign to us that they've reached
out to us and you know we will engage in
embracing those in those discussions is
openly and positively as we always do
how did have you have you mentioned this
fact I presume you have - Harry's
parents Charlotte Charles and Tim Dunn
how do they react like to the TV yeah
again they're sort of five hours ahead
so I get I only had a brief conversation
just to let them know the development
and you know as always they're good
people and they they see any new
development as a positive step forward
and this undoubtedly is a positive step
forward I know I know
the lawyer appointed by mrs. sue Kula
she's one of the foremost lawyers in not
only in Washington but in the country
and so I see it as a very positive step
and you know I'm sure that the
discussions will will move forward
positively and amicably and let's just
you know you always start these journeys
you never know where they're going to
end up but let's hope that we can
achieve a resolution to this terrible
tragedy sooner rather than later
yeah indeed I just wonder and
for people just joining us and who may
not have heard your previous statement
if you wouldn't mind if I if I said what
you what you told us and the media
before you left for the u.s. you said
the US government has claimed that
missus akula's has the benefit of
diplomatic immunity and has refused to
grant the waiver sought by the British
government and then you asked for anyone
on either side of the Atlantic who has
any information regarding her return to
the US before during or after her
departure to please come forward
does this meeting with her lawyer change
that request that you made in that
statement at all are you still you in
the family still seeking those things on
this trip most definitely so we we
figured out pretty early on that that
mrs. su coulis herself she made a
terrible mistake that night and you know
it it is what it is we can't turn the
clock back but we're more not more
concerned but we're also concerned at
the actions of the United States
government and the British government
and what role they both played in a the
Americans claiming that she had the
benefit of diplomatic immunity but you
just do disagree do you disagree with
that that assessment well we are we are
we are crystal clear but I'll repeat we
are crystal clear that she is she does
not have the benefit of diplomatic
immunity there's no doubt in our mind